para continuar analizando Este primer
año de la guerra en ucranianos acompañan
los estudios de France 24 Eugenia es
analista experta en relaciones
internacionales docente e investigadora
en la universidad externado de Colombia
Jenny Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en este programa especial de
France 24 como decíamos la guerra en
Ucrania llega a un año este 24 de
febrero analizamos en la primera hora de
esta programación especial un punto
clave que fue la otan pero pasemos ahora
a otro clave punto que te queremos
analizar y para el cual nos acompaña
también en los estudios nuestra
periodista experta en economía Daniela
hablando Daniela Muchísimas gracias por
estar en los estudios Hola Santiago Hola
María Clara Hola un placer estar aquí
también vamos a hablar ahora si les
parece María Daniela
de las sanciones no la guerra ocasionó y
desató toda una oleada de sanciones a
Rusia por parte de la Unión Europea de
Estados Unidos de la otan del g7 de
varios organismos y países aliados
occidentales impusieron muchísimas
sanciones el objetivo por supuesto es
Daniela debilitar a Rusia para que no
tenga recursos para financiar la guerra
ahogar las finanzas del crimen y por eso
casi todas desde un principio fueron
dirigidas Pues a sus principales
oligarcas y al kremlin y a sus
funcionarios Pero ha habido algo muy
llamativo Y es que casi no se han metido
con los hidrocarburos ya lo ha venido
haciendo últimamente pero desde el
principio dijeron no nos metamos todavía
con hidrocarburos Por qué Pues porque no
tienen autonomía digamos que por ejemplo
en Europa más del 40%
48% de los del gas viene de Rusia
entonces la Unión Europea no tiene
autonomía energética tampoco la tiene
por el momento Estados Unidos entonces
ahí necesitaban digamos de estos
recursos y Vladimir Putin lo sabe sin
embargo hubo unas sanciones y hubo
unas interdicciones de importación de
Rusia hacia la Unión Europea que le ha
costado más de siete billones de euros
Entonces eso es algo muy importante
menos
75% de exportaciones sobre el gas hacia
la Unión Europea Eso sí es importante
también hubo varias prohibiciones de
importaciones hacia Rusia de
punta de tecnología de tecnologías para
para hacer armas de guerra entonces
podemos ver que las sanciones son según
lo que le interesa también a la Unión
Europea y las sanciones energéticas como
bien ya lo decía Daniela no fueron las
primeras de hecho las primeras fueron en
contra del sistema financiero afectando
primero al Banco Central ruso luego
excluyendo a bancos rusos del denominado
sistema Swift que básicamente es un
sistema que permite mensajes
internacionales en la que los bancos de
todo el mundo se conectan para permitir
transacciones al excluirlos lo que
hacían era que estos bancos rusos
quedaran prácticamente desconectados
qué tanto impacto han tenido realmente
esto sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que
occidente esperaba que el pib de Rusia
redujera un 10% y a la final sólo ha
caído un 2% han sido efectivas estas
sanciones financieras muchísimo menos de
lo que se pensaba efectivamente
estas sanciones han sido mucho menos
efectivas Por qué Porque hay que
recordar que las sanciones no datan de
ayer las sanciones empezaron en 2014
fueron varias horas y el país ha sabido
reorganizar su economía más que todo han
buscado nueva han fortalecido una nueva
red de aliados menos mirando hacia el
oeste mirando más hacia el este ahora
tienen nuevos socios comerciales no
olvidamos que por ejemplo china se ha
posicionado como un nuevo socio
comercial de Rusia más 40 por ciento de
intercambios comerciales entre estos dos
países el Primer Ministro chino ha dicho
que las relaciones entre estos dos
países son sólidas como una roca
entonces podemos ver que Rusia ha sabido
reorga digamos su red de socios
económicos y además el sistema Swift ha
sido reemplazado rápidamente con un otro
sistema el sistema spfs que ha permitido
finalmente a Rusia desenvolverse en el
los mercados internacionales no tanto
hacia la Unión Europea y Estados Unidos
sino más bien sobre nuevos mercados
ahora Rusia aparece resistir verdad
según datos del gobierno Ruso y también
de la agencia internacional de energía
durante el 2022 incrementó un 2% su
producción de petróleo hablaban ustedes
de que el pib no casó finalmente tanto
como se esperaba se Estaba preparando
Rusia para este escenario de sanciones
quizás desde el conflicto en crimea sin
duda desde 2014 vinieron las sanciones
entonces Rusia se supo adaptar supo
tejer digamos una nueva red de socios
aliados Así que finalmente
estas sanciones que tenían que poner la
economía por el piso como la dicho el
fmi no ha pasado de hecho se produce que
para el 2023 la recesión digamos la
caída del pib será solamente de uno coma
ocho por ciento Rusia se está
aprovechando sin duda de los sus
recursos energéticos y de la alza del
precio de estos recursos Así que lo que
perdió por un lado lo supo reemplazar
por otro lado Claro pero también uno de
los principales argumentos del kremlin
es que estas sanciones han golpeado más
a occidente que a la misma Rusia Cómo
podemos describir también este panorama
entonces efectivamente hay muchas voces
en Europa que están condenando estas
sanciones a Rusia dicen por un lado son
ineficientes y por otro lado nos está
culpando a nosotros son las poblaciones
europeas que están sufriendo el daño
porque hay inflación porque el precio de
la energía ha aumentado además
[Música]
fortalecen a Rusia generan inflación
entonces
eso son Es una muy muy mala idea estas
sanciones hacia Rusia eso más que todo
por parte de los partidos extremistas
tanto extrema derecha como es extrema
izquierda que están condenando la
política que está mandando la Unión
Europea desde Bruselas Daniela bueno Y
en este aniversario se están planeando
más sanciones todavía verdad así de
Santiago porque el Primer Ministro de
Japón fue mioquia dijo hoy que los
líderes del g7 discutirán la imposición
de nuevas sanciones contra Rusia en una
Cumbre virtual que van a celebrar este
viernes y en la que va a participar el
presidente bolodimir selensky el g7
agrupa a Canadá Francia Alemania Italia
Japón Gran Bretaña y Estados Unidos y se
reúne justamente cuando los ministros de
finanzas del g-20 hacen lo propio en
India escuchemos por ejemplo que dijo el
ministro de finanzas francés al respecto
los juegos
por supuesto deberíamos imponer
sanciones adicionales Europa Lo está
pensando y trabajando en ello
y por cierto las sanciones son
eficientes todas son fuertes y
eficientes
y estoy profundamente convencido de que
a largo plazo lo serán cada vez más
debilitando la economía rusa y dando
todos los resultados concretos que
esperamos de ellas
bueno Ellos dicen que las sanciones Sí
están funcionando ahora le pregunto Oye
qué queda Por sancionar qué falta por
por sancionar en Rusia donde ya vemos
que llevamos una cascada de sanciones
enorme sí efectivamente han sido muchas
las sanciones de hecho ningún país ha
sido sancionado de esta manera como le
está haciendo ahora la Unión Europea
hacia Rusia que falta por solucionar
pues sin duda el petróleo que todavía no
está sancionado se ha sancionado el
gasto todavía no el petró porque la
Unión Europea sabe que no tiene esta
autonomía energética que le permitiría
tomar esta sanción otra vez vemos Que
Hay ciertos sectores de la industria
rusa que ha sido afectado esencialmente
el automóvil hoy en día Rusia Está
sacando automóviles que no tiene un
sistema de freno de abcn que no tiene
estos airbags porque le hace falta la
tecnología que se puede sancionar más se
va a cerrar Más aún el sistema
financiero y sin duda van a tener que
regular más aún las exportaciones de
hidrocarburos pero otra vez como estamos
viendo Rusia ya está mirando por otro
lado para exportar y precisamente uno de
los lados a los que está mirando es
hacia china e India con las cuales Ha
logrado tener un alivio en esa presión
que occidente está imponiendo con los
hidrocarburos Daniela cuéntenos un poco
más de estas crisis energéticas que está
pasando y como Rusia está haciendo el
frente pues mire el sufrimiento para la
economía mundial generalizado ya lo
sabemos suministro reducidos de cereales
y granos también fertilizantes y energía
junto con más inflación e incertidumbre
económica se podría hacer como el
panorama general a pesar de que el mundo
ya estaba lidiando con ambos por cuenta
de la pandemia ahora Rusia suministraba
Entonces el 40% de las necesidades
energéticas de la Unión Europea con la
invasión y las posteriores sanciones el
continente se enfrentó a ese desafío de
descubrir cómo iba a reemplazar
rápidamente ese gas y petróleo rusos que
todos los años pues mantenían o
protegían a las viviendas o a las
familias del invierno a nivel mundial el
primer impacto se sufrió cuando el
petróleo subió levemente a 139 dólares
el barril el año pasado volvió a caer
alrededor de 80 dólares por barril
después de que quedó claro que como dice
Eugene el efecto de las sanciones
occidentales sobre el volumen de las
exportaciones de Moscú pues había sido
más bien limitado y Cuál es la situación
Daniela hoy un año luego de la invasión
de la de Rusia a Ucrania entonces Europa
ha nuevos vendedores y Moscú nuevos
compradores como decía María Clara para
sus productos energéticos que son el
alma de su economía por ejemplo en Asia
China o India que le compran petróleo
con un buen descuento y ha mantenido el
suministro de bienes de consumo a través
de un esquema de importaciones que ha
sido bastante criticado porque permite
ingresar productos al país sin la
autorización del fabricante original
también se están aislando mutuamente con
los mercados occidentales que le
ayudaron también a impulsar su
crecimiento después de la caída de la
unión soviética y háganos un repaso de
Qué ha pasado con estos precios pues
mire los precios del gas como vamos a
ver a continuación han caído hasta un
85% desde que alcanzaron un punto máximo
en verano estábamos en precios de Entre
10 20 euros por megavatio hora en enero
de 2020 fueron subiendo y ya para la
invasión se dispararon hasta los 300 más
allá de 300 por mega 300 euros por
megavatio hora desde entonces ha venido
bajando
[Música]
bajando está entre los 50 euros por
megavatio hora aproximadamente y ahora
el problema estos inclusive antes menos
de lo que está de que antes de que
estallara el conflicto los gobiernos
europeos cuál es el problema que los
gobiernos europeos han tenido que gastar
casi 800 mil millones de euros en
subsidios de energía para los hogares Y
para las empresas y se están preguntando
cuánto tiempo pueden mantener cuánto
tiempo pueden mantenerse entonces
subsidiando la energía a la gente no
mucho más y creo que los gobiernos de
Europa han sido bastante claros sobre
eso Por ejemplo en Francia del gobierno
macu ha dicho que el bucle es decir el
escudo tarifario en el cual había un
bloqueo del precios de la energía para
que no pasara una cierta un cierto
precio ya se va a acabar Durante los
últimos meses las facturas tanto de
energía de gas de Electricidad han
subido un 20% Y es probable ha anunciado
ya el gobierno mccon que suban de un 15%
cada mes yo quiero una pregunta porque
si bien un poco la estrategia de Rusia
como lo estábamos viendo era ahogar a
occidente a través de los precios del
gas que es una de las tres
características que se requiere para
este hidrocarburo y es la accesibilidad
esta vez mediante el precio hacer que
los precios suban como nos lo estaba
mostrando Daniela Pero por otra parte
occidente ha respondido imponiéndole
límites a los crudos al crudo ruso
inicialmente lo hizo el g7 y Australia
en diciembre de 2022 que prohibió que
cualquier barril ruso que valiera más de
60 dólares y entrara a la Unión Europea
o a los países miembros del g7 o
circulará incluso por sus mares y luego
en febrero de 2023 la Unión Europea
decide tomar una sanción similar que
tanto ha afectado esto a Rusia Bueno lo
ha afectado muy de manera muy limitado
porque finalmente como dijimos ya Rusia
se estaba buscando nuevos socios
entonces lo que se perdía por un lado se
está ganando por otro lado Entonces está
exportando hacia china hacia India hacia
Turquía hacia incluso
algería entonces ahí Rusia no tiene
tanto problemas como tiene la Unión
Europea que realmente se dio cuenta que
soberanía energética no tiene y que ya
está trabajando No Solamente sobre unos
nuevos socios que los podría brindar
esta esta energía pero también están
preparando la transición energética no
solamente por razones económicas y
ecológicas pero también porque se dan
cuenta que no tienen otra opción una de
las consecuencias más problemáticas no
de la guerra en Ucrania ha sido la
crisis alimentaria Daniela Sí Santiago
antes de la guerra Ucrania y Rusia
ostentaban casi una tercera parte de las
exportaciones mundiales de trigo una
quinta parte del Maíz y un 80% del
aceite de girasol también eran los
principales proveedores mundiales Y eso
hay que hacer énfasis de África Oriente
medio y partes de Asia y allá ya muchos
estaban luchando históricamente contra
la inseguridad alimentaria rusa también
era su principal proveedor de y la
guerra interrumpió todo eso tenemos
casos concretos de países afectados Como
por ejemplo Egipto que es el importador
número uno de trigo del mundo
cómo ha sido Entonces esta crisis para
estos países y se ve al corto plazo que
puedan superarla Bueno lo más importante
no es el corto plazo sino que va a ser
el largo plazo porque estamos
efectivamente en un escenario en el cual
no hay soberanía alimentaria Y eso
sabemos que puede desencadenar en varios
problemáticas inestabilidad política
refugiados
todo una un conjunto de factores que
pueden desestabilizar a la a la a la
región Entonces eso es un problema sin
embargo miramos que Ucrania por ejemplo
que estaba
exportando 5 millones de toneladas al
mes hoy en día está en la posibilidad de
exportar sobre solamente uno punto cinco
millones de toneladas al mes eso es un
problema lo hemos visto genera inflación
en la Unión Europea todavía está
controlado por los organismos como la
FAO internacionales que se pueden que
pueden comprar en los mercados
internacionales pero el problema es que
empiezan a tener efectivamente problemas
para encontrar todos estos insumos en
los mercados mundiales así que sin duda
el reto no es tanto a corto plazo sino
más bien a largo plazo y el reto es
principalmente para los países altamente
dependientes de estas importaciones como
ya lo decía Daniela Egipto es la Clara
muestra de esto quizás Europa no siente
tanto los coletazos pues no depende en
igual medida que lo hacen países
africanos y esta reducción que usted nos
habla de cinco millones a uno coma cinco
millones de toneladas solo hablando de
los granos de Ucrania claramente está
sofocando y está provocando la crisis
alimentaria en muchas partes del mundo
Daniela sin embargo en julio del año
pasado un poco para evitar esto con la
mediación de Turquía tanto Ucrania como
Rusia llegaron a un acuerdo para
permitir la salida a través del mar
Negro de diferentes buques cargados con
los granos de ambos países qué ha pasado
desde entonces pues mire se ha venido
renovando ese acuerdo desde julio ya en
la más reciente extensión pues vence el
próximo mes Ucrania ya pidió que se
extienda por un año más pero Rusia ha
señalado que no está contenta con
algunos aspectos y solicitó que se
levantaran las sanciones que afectan a
sus exportaciones agrícolas y es que
estas exportaciones como tal no están
explícitamente sancionadas pero el dice
que los bloqueos de sus industrias de
pagos por ejemplo o logística son una
barrera para que puedan exportar sus
propios granos y sus propios
fertilizantes quiero también darles unas
cifras rápidamente Y es que según el
programa mundial de alimentos 345
millones de personas están en
inseguridad grave alimentaria en ese
momento y de ese total 47 millones de
personas lo están Gracias o debido más
bien a la guerra en Ucrania
Bueno muchísimas gracias Daniela por tu
análisis en materia económica vamos